Battle Star Galactica has a new
showrunner who is it and what do we
think welcome to CRA TVM Movie
Channel the cner was a TV show starring
Bill Pullman it was a TV show about
another one of those quite boring
detectives if I'm 100% honest trying to
find out why normal people it would seem
commit really atrocious crimes I
actually saw the first series starring
Jessica be and I have to admit I never
bothered watching anymore I found it
quite boring but the showrunner and
creator of that series Derek Simmons has
been chosen as the new showrunner for
the Battle Star Galactica series now Sam
esmail is still involved in this now he
was supposed to be showrunning and
writing it before the strikes basically
and during the strikes it's now been
decided to go in a different direction I
think partly because Sam isma's list of
projects is sort of back up a little bit
he's got other things he's doing and he
really doesn't have time for balar
Galactica as well so Derek has been
brought in Derek will be writing and
executive producing the series and
directing several of the episodes this
will still be a direct to stream in um
direct to Peacock series and we'll still
be looking at around 10 episodes filming
is supposed to start reasonably soon I
was told it'll be in the spring but now
it looks like we might actually be
looking at total rewrite for the series
so don't be surprised if that gets
pushed back
again so what can we expect from this
writer well he is a seriously good
writer don't get me wrong I my problem
with the siner wasn't that it was badly
written or badly created in any way I it
was just a little bit too slow for me it
felt like they were doing um something
that was in line with sort of those
Norwegian murder mysteries that have
been so very popular the last few years
very dark very gritty very slow paced
and to to be honest it's just not for me
that doesn't mean it was bad it wasn't
it was probably very good just not my
cup of tea so he would bring something
different to Battle Star Galactica I can
never see that he has any history of
doing anything particularly sci-fi he
did a series that only lasted one season
called s of the astronauts uh Wives Club
which was sort of a TV series I think it
was about the Apollo missions and it was
there the wives of the different
astronauts and it was about them that's
the closest thing to sci-fi has ever
done that I can see so we're going to
get a creator that is maybe well doesn't
have a Sci-Fi background let's put it
that way so what can we expect from the
series well look he's a bit of an
unknown I have to be honest because he's
not done it before Sam asmail is staying
on board he's still going to be an
executive producer but even Sam Ismail
really didn't have a vast history in
this type of thing
but Battlestar Galactica is more of a
serious sci-fi so he might he might suit
this I don't think we're going to know
really until it comes out or we start
seeing some of the early work what we
can though assume is this is going to be
probably more like a reboot now a
reimagined version of Battle Star
Galactica rather than what we initially
had which was going to be sort of a
continuation or something that existed
within at very least the Ronald De Moore
version of battl star now that it looks
like the movie is no longer happening
that was also apparently going to be
sort of within Universe somehow it does
look like this is going to be a boots up
reimagined version of Battle Star a
complete
reboot I'm not sure how I feel about
that I think there's a big enough
Universe there that they could have done
something else but the problem is that
youan can't call it Battlestar Galactica
and people want Battlestar Galactica so
I I think this is a bit of a problem
similar to what um J Michael zinski got
we bringing back Babylon 5 and he's
talked about how he can't do a prequel
or anything because nobody wants to see
it so he has to do another Babylon 5
series instead if he ever gets a chance
to make that so we have someone new at
the helm of Battlestar Galactica we're
going to have to wait and see what he
does with it I am though a little bit
concerned because I have to admit the
first version of this the Ronald more
version of this I should say I found a
little bit dull and I have to admit I
stopped watching after a while even
though the miniseries was some of the
greatest SC I've ever seen so let's see
and fingers crossed he can do a good job
but guys get into the comments tell me
what you think did you watch cner did
you enjoy it did he give you some
insight into what this Creator is about
and what he would bring to Battle Star
get into the comments and tell everyone
and if you are new to the channel
pleasee like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out in
you never miss any of our videos as
always please stay safe and I'll see you
next
[Music]
time